if you're looking for success in 2024 in
real estate as a service provider maybe
you're in mortgage or maybe you're just
a professional overall this might be one
of the most important videos you watch
because I want to share with you three
quick tips for I think the mindset we
need to scale our income really survive
a real estate recession and ultimately
survive and thrive in 2024 when it comes
to uh real estate and then we're also
going to be doing some coaching with two
special guests today so if you look at
the time codes of this video You' be
able to skip around to learn um really
some tactics for how do I use YouTube to
Market my business and here's some of
the benefits that we're ultimately kind
of after you know by tapping into
YouTube you can increase leads and sales
you can create extra income streams you
can build a Recession Proof personal
brand you can increase transactions to
get new clients you can rise to the top
2% of any Market you can learn how to
get free leads and not have to cold call
there's passive prospecting
opportunities because you make a YouTube
video once and it keeps getting viewed
for weeks months and years to come you
could build your brand by building up
your online presence building up an
online Brand It ultimately allows you to
work less but ultimately make more money
and attract High net worth clients what
what is one transaction worth to you
what would it be worth to attract a high
net worth client and ultimately build a
system so unlimited business is coming
your way maybe enough to get through how
slow transactions are right now but then
ultimately to thrive as the market
shifts as rates change who knows what
the future holds um so that you can do
more of what you love scaling your
business scaling up and spending time
with your family going on better
vacations and all that kind of stuff so
three quick tips and then we're going to
dive into our first guest this is the
coffee with canel show if you're new
here smash like and today's episode is
actually brought to you by realu
class.com I just finished up an hourong
Long training where I got really
tactical totally free The Limited
replays available you can check that out
in the description I'll tell you a
little bit more about that later but I
just wrote down three really important
things that anybody can benefit I know
that a lot of our community is not doing
real estate a lot of our community here
is doing um YouTube DIY all kinds of
different niches niches you know
whatever and so uh what I would say is
here number one is learn new skills so
Harvard Business
review uh did a study of 3,500 managers
and what they discovered was two
shocking statistics the first one was
only three out of 10 new hires at a
business have the necessary skills to
even do their job right now at a
satisfactory or above satisfactory level
what does that mean well if you work
somewhere and you're coming on or if
you're coming into the creater economy
or if you're a newer agent or even a
season agent there's probably still some
skills you need to learn right there's a
skill Gap only three out of 10 people
have enough skills adequate for these
different professional disciplines
question for you do you have the
adequate skills to not succeed in real
estate when the market is frothy and the
money printers are on and just
everything's being lifted up and really
you were just conducting transactions
managing transactions as opposed to
being a real estate professional right
so it's this idea of learning new skills
but the second stat is really shocking
what they revealed was that if you want
to stay
relevant stay effective and prepare for
the future that professionals need to
learn 10 new skills every 18 months
Harvard Business Review you can look up
the article 3500 managers surveyed only
three out of 10 are ready now and in the
next 18 months if you don't learn 10
skills then you're going to start
falling behind what does that mean AI
crms online marketing YouTube social
media also things we can I mean in real
estate you would think about the like
specific skills likees for some it's
like oh in real estate I just you know
manage the deal no it's like or I just
have to get leads and get them going no
managing the whole transaction being
able to oh shoot we have a financing
issue can we fix that and you're the
professional so you know all those
different things so number one if we're
going to thrive in 2024 we got to commit
to learning new skills 100% of us real
estate or not right we have to be like
okay what are the necessary skills for
the next level am I embracing AI what's
the latest technology what other
software could help me go faster and
then of course in YouTube definitely
subscribe because we're here to help you
learn skills with YouTube thumbnails
titles what to say in videos and in just
a second we'll get into some of that
content but number two to win in
2024 you need to fall in love with Sam
did you see that one coming it's true
you need to fall in love with Sam Sean
I'm already married that's okay if you
are in business if you're a
professional you need to date Sam as
well Sean that's really weird what are
you talking about Sam stands for sales
and
marketing one of the things that's
actually interesting is we want to just
be good with people how to win friends
and influence people we want to just you
know shake hands we want to just can I
just avoid sales and marketing no no you
can actually and one of the things of
mindset shifts I've learned is that
whatever your role is you might be the
primary agent you might be a loan
officer whatever and and you might be
mid compan so this might not be the Hat
you're wearing but the mindset we all
need to adapt is that we are actually
like our own Chief marketing officer
that is my
responsibility to not just do the thing
but to be the main proponent of
marketing the thing because content is
King but marketing is Queen and she runs
the household so it's like okay or or or
doing the service is King but marketing
you doing the service is Queen and she
runs the household like mastering
marketing and mastering sales I'm GNA
help you get leads with um YouTube for
your real estate business especially at
our class real tube class we go into
that real tube class.com we're going to
talk about it some of our coaching in
just a second and again free class in
the description but but that's only one
piece of the pie too right that's the
marketing piece but when you when they
call you or when they text you are you
following up quick there's that other
MIT study that after five minutes it is
times harder for that lead to respond if
you don't follow up with the lead that
comes in I looked it up you know back
when I've shopped in different markets
and we do some real estate investing my
wife and I and like we use Zillow a
little bit and you know now I avoid it
but I type my information in once you
know to see like you start getting phone
calls from Zillow and they try to place
you with somebody or whatever but I just
remember too in in I was in Las Vegas we
were looking for a house and I typed my
information to Google or it's a Zillow
and then the Zillow lady was like the
automated robot was like all right we're
gonna place you and then like the phone
started ringing and like the person
didn't lift uh pick up you know that
Zillow leads can be anywhere from 30 to
50 to
$150 sometimes it's like $500 a month to
get leads from Zillow um it could be as
much as like a thousand a month and
maybe you're paying per individual lead
but I was looking in like Grand Rapids
Michigan it was like a thousand doll a
month to Google Zillow forgive me what's
the point like even just getting the
lead you got to follow up with the lead
2024 we got to master sales and
marketing we got to be saying I in fact
you don't want to just date Sam you need
to marry Sam like it's ongoing you
should wake up with Sam every day and
get to work because it's like I got to
do the thing I got to fulfill my product
I got to be world class I want to be
excellent I want to make great videos
but I need to master sales in
marketing and number
three if in 2024 not just in real estate
but for our whole coffee with Cano
community and think media Community we
need to stay
positive I think that one of the biggest
challenges we're all facing right
now is between our two ears is this
battlefield for the mind
as we go into 2024 some have called it
the year of chaos chaos in the economy
chaos in
geopolitics chaos in culture wars and
division chaos in the real estate market
chaos in interest rates chaos in no
inventory chaos in transactions in sish
County where I am right now transactions
right now my friend Anton was telling me
are as slow and as low as
2011 there a different market now you're
all in unique markets but it's a
different market right how how how many
rate drops are going to happen next year
what's what's GNA happen and then what
are also the opportunities though what's
the opportunities with the new OPP you
know for oh you only have to put 5% down
on a fourplex and and um or four units
right four doors um and so you could
start h house hacking and these
different things number three stay
positive this isn't poana staying
positive is not being delusional
but I think that in 2024 if we're going
to thrive on YouTube if we're going to
thrive in business if we're going to
make it through whatever comes our way
we need mental toughness we Face the
brutal facts with unwavering optimism so
I encourage you I hope that was valuable
and we always do sometimes like a little
opening uh little bit of value here in
coffee with canel 2024 you want to crush
it number one commit to learning new
skills number two fall in love with Sam
who Sam sales and marketing and number
three stay positive hey shout out where
are you watching from what do you
sipping on what are you drinking today I
got a little bit of uh you know coffee
as it is the coffee with candle show so
let's get into
[Music]
it
welcome back to the coffee with canel
show we have two special guests today
but let me know how are you doing we're
going to go to Sarah in just a second
and then Justin but shout me out where
you watching from in the world share
this especially with somebody that's
maybe in real estate different Niche
title than we usually do hyper Niche you
know we're usually much broader than
this but I got a special place in my
heart for Real Estate One I personally
love it too I have an odd number of
friends and peers speak at a lot of
different real estate events speak for
my friend Neil dingra at a mortgage
event really mostly loan officers um
have done many presentations in
different whatever so really uh our
theme today is real estate and also
today's coffee with can is brought to
you by realu class.com but without
further Ado we're going to get ready for
Sarah here Justin sipping on coffee we
got California finishing my coffee at
latte with espresso shots that sounds
really good okay good to see yall good
to see you Angelique good to see we got
Drea here Zusi thanks so much for being
here all right Sarah tell us a little
bit about what you're doing thanks so
much for jumping on and uh let's uh
tackle some of your questions today
first introduce yourself hi I'm Sarah
Driscoll I have been selling real estate
for 40 years I'm in San Diego California
and my channel is about uh providing
some hopefully interesting information
for home sellers amazing so when did you
start your
channel uh a few months ago excellent
excellent 18 videos um before we get
into your questions what was the hardest
thing right at the start for posting
your first videos what was going through
your mindset what was was there any
resistance did you do you wish you
started your YouTube channel sooner and
was there anything that caused you to
hesitate or did you just finally get
around to it well in my industry my
colleagues are all talking about video
video video and what they mean by that
is they do a video and posted on social
media so goes on Facebook or Instagram
something like that and then it's you
know I mean then people forget so we
decided I work with my husband um but we
decided that we would start doing that
and before we could get started with
actually doing the videos we realized
what we really meant was start a YouTube
channel and create content a library of
content that would live for a while so
that became the the rabbit hole of
learning and we found V fortunately and
so we spent a lot of time learning I
guess the biggest um obstacle to getting
started was we figured out we had to
learn some things first and then we find
finally jumped in and did it yes yeah
definitely skills to learn and I'm
pulling up one of your videos here
awesome all right well um hit me with
your first
question I am not good at at rocketing I
need to figure out how to get the videos
in front of the Right audience which is
San Diego home sellers awesome okay well
let's dive in here to some Niche
specific thing okay
um first thing I would do is is you know
in in our V we talk about the seven RS
reverse engineer and research which
speaks to topics being one of the
biggest opportunities and so if I'm you
and I'm in s San Diego the first thing
on a simple level and inside of RA we
have many different keyword research
tools but the YouTube search bar and the
autor predict feature of it could
probably give us a lot of information
when we just typed in San Diego real
estate and here's one of the things that
I want to want you to see but everybody
watching to see as
well when I look at your channel and I
see the titles that you've done and the
fact you're telling me that you want
influence in San Diego I actually only
see the word San Diego in one title this
isn't going to be helpful because San
Diego uh Sarah Drisco San Diego realer
is is a more of a trailer right so that
wasn't me it not as much of an Outreach
video but when I T tap in San Diego real
estate St you know this very sometimes
hidden in plain s side information is
saying in order some of the
topics or the topics that people are on
the internet wanting the most so this is
why I would always
encourage doing Market updates and also
Market updates is not a once a year
thing it could be I think minimum once a
month it could be maximum once a week
how much business or awareness do you
want and
that these probably these are not V
viral videos but these are a big
opportunity
to um start to get in front of people so
what do we see though in order here we
see first of all maybe just information
about the market in general or a market
update what we also realize we talk
about this all the time and
V and that
is that we're about to be in January as
the year as the clock turns over um
there's a whole new all old it's not
that all old videos become irrelevant
but humans want recency that we want the
newest information as soon as it's 2024
I don't really want 2023 information so
the agents that
hustle in the next eight weeks and
really think about strategic 2024
content are going to be most powerfully
positioned now I think that uh tours
are that's a debate we could have
another time or you know or now but like
I think it's totally fine individual
listings you know are interesting
because maybe um not only might you sell
the listing but it could attract people
the problem is they're not as broad
appeal right that's that's where I say
so do you have to do listings you don't
I think you can do listings but again
all we're doing is this first page we
just typed in San Diego real estate
crash of course it it is San Diego real
estate going to crash well here's what
Nar says here's what you know you go on
okay forecast have you made a
predictions video for the next year and
so this was off you know just our first
basic step but sometimes and I don't I
don't blame you sometimes it's a you
know a challenge a lot of us have uh we
I love the Michael Jordan quote it's
like Master the fundamentals and
everything else you do will rise so
inside of RA and inside of V Masters we
could get into much more advanced
tactics but the basic thing I look at on
your Channel you're very professional
Communicator your ability to produce
videos and you've put out videos but
these videos aren't like the first five
videos I would even do like the most
basic foundational to just start getting
some hand-to-hand awareness of you in
San Diego in particular where there
could be deal flow and you're more aware
than anybody that if if we just get one
transaction that would be great if we
could get three in the next 45 days that
would be amazing in addition into
whatever else so um you don't need a ton
of views I want to get in front of these
types of uh topics how what do you think
about this
feedback I think it's great do I need to
incorporate San Diego or I guess into
titles or how do I bring that in oh
absolutely because YouTube is still the
second largest search engine in the
world it's also the actual primary
search engine of certain
consumers so I would want angles like
moving to San Diego pros and cons moving
to San Diego I then see the opportunity
of you
identifying like if we were to
draw dart board and if the term San
Diego was a
bullseye is North County south county is
there any other cities beach cities is
Coronado Island are any of these things
still on that artboard if they La
probably is not so that's probably too
far but what topics are on there and
then I would methodically specifically
city names or location names or County
names or region names I would want to
over
time hit all of those that is capable
for me to serve because the the niche
thing could be somebody that knows
they're moving and wants to buy a house
and knows they're moving give me one
kind of like more specific City or
something within San Diego or region or
County
Del sorry what would it be delmare yeah
so delmare so then you saying like pros
and cons of Delmar or maybe it's the Ang
angle of education and you know schools
and crime rates the family searching for
that the father who's like shopping in
delmare and looking for information
searching on either Google or YouTube
can then find that video and be like oh
wow man Sarah's cool like oh that was
really great information I can see she
cares about families boom reaches out
hey we're ready to buy like we're
pre-approved and
delare was the
angle that someone searched to find you
and what we teach a VRA is like ranking
in a 2024 World is also that suggested
World which could be like let's go viral
usually on YouTube it's like housing
crash type of like that's sometimes
Trend surfing but I would want to put
out as many the analogy is also is kind
of like fishing and you may have heard
me say this at be all right I remember
going on a a date with my mom to I think
wibby island or the San Juan Island so
we went to mleo in the Pacific Northwest
to get on the ferry the ferry wasn't
there yet so we got some lattes and
walked down on the dock and we saw a guy
there who was in a beach chair and he
had like eight fishing poles up against
the railing of um you know the dock
there and as I was thinking in my mind I
was like this is smart maybe it's
illegal I don't know if the game warden
would approve this but somebody else
that's into fishing would know uh but
this is smart because rather than just
having the one hook in the ocean he's
got eight and he can sit back and then
one of those could ultimately be the one
that catches even just a fish so the
difference between him going home with
nothing or him going home with one or
two fish could be the amount of at bats
or the amount of videos he actually put
out into the ocean so a lot of the
different videos and and you're already
getting 73 views 236 like these are good
amounts of views if you're getting right
in front of the right people so that's
definitely where I would start is is um
little by little creating just quality
helpful valuable content around these
different entry points uh related to San
Diego delmare and other things like
that I appreciate that I a lot of
Realtors are looking for buyers and I
actually am looking more for sellers I'm
not that interested in finding total
strangers to work with to buy a home
well and we say the Creator who
understands the viewer best wins or the
business owner who understands their
Avatar or the person they most
powerfully positioned to help or if you
just understand that that is the better
strategy or this like you said they're
you're looking for something somebody I
think content around um eight tips for
getting your home ready to sell how to
get position your home to make more
money how to and the opportunity for
Real Estate though is again there's
there's the macro opportunity which I
would argue is Nationwide for someone
living in the US general information
that could lead to bigger amounts of
views and the really cool thing about
YouTube is you can have extra income
streams eventually you might be
monetized and that's in its own income
stream probably won't be a lot unless
you get really big but for some for
think media it's $40,000 a month it's
pretty ridiculous so it could be
definitely there's all kinds of other
ways to earn in income saying
that if you start niching down like
specific tips for earning more in San
Diego so you start crafting a title like
you know 10 things to know to sell your
home for maximum
for the maximum price in San Diego that
title was not refined but that would be
the essence of it like something like
that and
again the greater Clarity for everybody
a coffee with k watching the greater
Clarity you have on like the exact
person you want to help or the exact
pain point or the desire the greater
idea Clarity you have on who your ideal
client is then that influences the
content you make to attract your ideal
client so you saying that you know I
hope that maybe helps too is that um
that would steer your strategy with the
goal of attracting viewers that you're
most powerfully positioned to
help thank you has this been a good
conversation Sarah you getting some
value and some ideas going absolutely I
have some work to do awesome well I
appreciate you thanks so much for
jumping
on oh appreciate you Sarah kind of cut
her off there but listen uh what was
your aha moment from that last uh part
listen you if you're here and you see
the title and like I'm not in real
estate well then yeah you don't need to
stick around but actually if you're
noticing um some of the strategy we're
doing here definitely applies for
business owners service providers of all
kinds that's kind of a different angle
with a different objective we're
actually not trying to go viral we're
just trying to attract the uh best type
of clientele um we're just trying to get
one or two or three views hopefully
those are people that end up calling us
or jumping on our email list or emailing
us or text messaging us so we can follow
up and serve them and I like to think of
real estate as high ticket affiliate
marketing so you know like I get 4% of a
camera and so if a
camera maximum is is ,000 or let's say
it's $ th000 then I make $40 pretty cool
um but if it's really hard to you know
get enough clicks to get
enough Amazon clicks to sell that now
it's imagine this like you're an
affiliate for
lipstick and it's
$10 and you make 4% what' you make 40
cents okay well then think about real
estate how much is a home in San Diego a
million
dollars 3%
commission it's
$30,000 so real estate is kind of like
high ticket affiliate marketing
different but but we don't need viral
amounts of views we just want to get the
right views a few views we want to be
really clear how we can you you know
collect uh their information so we can
follow up and serve
individuals um we're going to go to
Justin here in a second but after that
if You' got questions put four question
marks before and after your question um
and we'll jump to that and then today's
episode is brought to you by realtube
class.com for the first time ever I felt
like I had so much real estate energy
pent up and uh someone asked me we were
running like ads on Instagram they said
are you an agent I was like like no I'm
not I said uh but I am an investor have
bought and sold different properties
have done some long-term rental stuff
have done some short-term rental stuff
airbnb's and uh I'm obsessed with
YouTube and generally I'd say real
estate's kind of like a big side hobby
for me and then we have a Litany of
students we've helped start and grow
their YouTube channels in the real
estate space friends with people like
Ryan pan real estate Legend pace morie
Michael Zuber daily financial news Anton
ster who's kind of a mogul up in the SN
homish area so so while I can't qualify
to be a real estate professional
according to the IRS because of my
amount of hours I put into think media
and why I would never actually claim to
be a real estate professional I got a
few I got a little bit of some stuff
under my belt I think I can talk shop
and I definitely can help you get
results on YouTube because my specialty
would be helping you rank videos turn
those views into lead s and even helping
you uh you know follow up on your leads
more powerfully because there's a lot of
there's a lot of substance under the
surface of think media in terms
of uh sales things like that what's the
point realtube class.com will not be a
waste of your time one hour free On
Demand right now because the replay is
coming down Friday which is in 36 hours
or something and so uh we're going to
jump into Justin here and then I will
jump I see some questions coming in so
Justin welcome to coffee with canel Sean
canel I'm honored to be here my guy uh
good to see you remind everybody what
you're up to what you're doing yes so I
mean we first met on clubhouse I Peak
Clubhouse you poured into me um I run
two channels I have the prime real
estate brokerage Channel which we're
talking about today I am I guess if you
took Ryan sirant and Peter McKinnon and
they had a baby I guess that would be me
I use storytelling to sell properties I
run a team out of Southwestern Ontario
Canada um and we do a whole bunch of
different types of videos and just
looking for a little bit more clarity um
on how to run the
channel beautiful this looks crispy
where's this uh Studio that's my office
yeah that's my main office studio just
what a flex Justin's out oh oh bro
that's just my office just I'm just
surrounded by
Windows um I've got a a ray gun next to
me so if anybody messes with me uh that
what is that a it's a ray gun it it's a
light actually so the Graham Stefan
effect he had that same light in one of
his videos it was from Restoration
Hardware we bought it like 10 years ago
but that little piece has actually
helped us quite a bit in her videos
that's so rad it reminds me of um Mars
uh invasions or whatever Mars Invasion
whatever movie that was that was a crazy
movie okay that's a side quest um and
side note just for some tips for viewers
a video structured like this really
really good um Trend surfing don't buy
real estate until you watch this video
then doing time codes and chapters very
smart very helpful for uh
viewers um 10 predictions okay I do
think if we were to just kind of Niche
down I'm getting very granular right up
at the start I do
wonder if like
2024 in the title I think that would be
helpful cool uh titles still carry a lot
of weight tags don't uh description
doesn't carry much titles carry a lot I
think actually in
Search and also in Google and and
there's going to be of course a lot of
people doing this right now though so
you got a lot of competition but 2024
real estate real estate predictions that
doesn't come up okay oh yeah because no
one's done doing it yet so real
estate
predictions 2024 I mean it's the first
thing Canada it's interesting you get
more niche
where are you based we're based in
London Ontario and surrounding regions
so in Canada just north of Michigan so
and that's also maybe the ambition here
is fine but the ambition here to just
it's like this what is this worldwide
you know like Global as a nation like I
think that's very fascinating to
me um and here's what we just discovered
Together live on coffee with canel I'm
get I think this is okay there's one
right here three weeks
ago there is
is and not that great and not great
content compared to yours you have the
opportunity at this you have the
opportunity to actually change your
title and thumbnail this because it
looks like the video is a fire up to you
because it's it's not popping off yet
and so
um but again what we're seeing is
there's not even a good answer to that
query specifically based on Canada and
so a huge mindset that I'd want you to
have and everybody else watching this is
that sometimes I think I'm all for like
let's just go try to take down Goliath
but I think that actually is we're
building up our channels I'd much rather
slay some lions tigers and bears first
to get prepared for Goliath and kind of
build up the channel Authority and that
would be looking for those Niche deals
so being in
Canada I would much and May and I think
you could still change the title but
this is also why reverse engineer and
research is so important because if we
know what direction we're going for then
it influences everything hey are you
looking for a house in Canada are you
worried about the market what about this
and that and and it refines our
information this is a huge I was
thinking about this even in blogging
they talk about this is kind of what
niching means not just in your brand but
in
content that sometimes too it's very
hard to create like it's hard to create
content for the global real estate
market maybe almost impossible because
it's so different so you have and then
it's even hard to create content for
Nationwide America because doomers and
all these different people they say
certain things but they they may only
point to One Market to prove that where
there's another Market that disproves
that so in anything if rather if I try
to talk about advice for every camera
well it starts getting really blurry but
if I Niche down to one camera all of a
sudden it becomes clear it's like these
are the five things you need to know
about this camera so anyways it's a long
way of saying I do think there's
something interesting about focusing on
Canada what are your thoughts yeah I
think it makes a ton of sense the
inspiration for the video is Sir who's a
friend of mine and and my mentor and you
know he's really talking about the
states I'm talking about Canada so being
more specific makes sense I guess that
leads to the second question that I had
in terms of My overall Channel because
we do referrals all over North America
like we send stuff down to Texas I got
Partners in Tennessee Florida we sent
stuff to like the UK and Israel last
year how do you capture the leads so it
was literally just by doing the videos
and telling them hey if you want to work
with us just send us an email they come
to our email and then we would
distribute them to our Network because
we're plugged into three like big and
how do you track commissions like what
do you end up with like 1% on that or
half or something 25% so if they get two
or three% of the oh you get 25% of their
their got it exactly so it goes directly
into my CRM we capture it actually with
a Google form it goes to my VA she
actually puts it into our deals board so
we can see all of our referrals
throughout the year and exactly where
they're at so it's a pipeline of
business for us and I guess that's why I
try to do General real estate V content
but as you're speaking I do think
because our channel is still in its
growth stage speaking to Canada first
and then indicating that we can do
referrals worldwide in the content might
be the play as we're growing because if
I'm trying to speak to everybody I'm
kind of speaking to nobody right yeah
well the other play is it's not either
or it's it's a both game
meaning if I sit down in preparation and
I'm you with the knowledge and
experience and brand you have I sit down
and I
say okay it would be good to do a
broader appeal North America video so
that's like thing one but now that I
think about it it would also be good to
do a niche predictions for Canada okay
that's video two okay and then now that
I think about it maybe I should hit the
us because even though okay so I'm
actually gonna make three videos so I'm
not going to release them all in the
same all right I'm G to release those 10
days apart here's how they this one
might be titled and then here's here's
my 10 predictions
six of these actually literally overlap
every Market but now I just am using the
same information but I'm positioning and
packaging it different these four are
different so okay I got to fix this this
I got to fix that now it took a little
bit longer quite a bit of time like so I
might I might sit down if I'm preparing
really crafted video podcasts which we
do two a week at think media many are
interviews but if I'm crafting you know
solo rounds it might take hours
but I'm I've got podcast through
the end of January now
so every minute spent planning has like
a 100x return on energy and Roi if it
takes a little bit longer because now
you've got three
bangers perfectly kind of position each
one's a little bit more articulate
because it's so specifically striking
the mark of the title and then it also
increases your odds the ultimate effort
because you just sit there the whole
time you know you like deliver basically
video one two three do you have an
editor helping you I do yeah I got a
great creative director yeah so it's
like you're able
to sit here a little bit longer how long
do this take you to record 20 minutes
edit it down to 10 yeah 20 yeah then
it's just an hour takes an hour kind of
goes into your workflow and what
happened because there sometimes some
things about YouTube I've learned is
also kind of like a law of averages
meaning we were just doing a a
coaching uh kind of thing on Zoom with
our V Elite group and what did I uh I
was like okay 2024 game plan let's do
some goal setting okay great how many
videos you want to do a week well you
can do more than somebody else because
you got team systems and other things
but I'm like you should definitely I
think a baseline is a long form meaning
not a YouTube short high
effort video per week and high effort
could be self-defined but just means
like not like in your car and you wung
it and like but like you you thought
about like you and you went through the
seven RS like you really researched and
reverse engineered and title and
thumbnail okay so one a week and then I
was like
if our goal would be 25% of those rank
if you're brand new one out of 10 oh I
mean one out of 10 if one out of 10
ranks by definition vfm viral for me uh
and I'm just getting started and in real
estate again if whe whether somebody
invests in our program I'm always
fighting to get them in Roi shoot they
only need one transaction and they could
2x 5x 10x their investment great
punchline is by doing the three videos
one might only have 52 views and maybe
never pops off the second one oh gets a
couple thousand you're pumped but then
the third one gets 150,000 and you
didn't realize that was actually GNA be
like the North America one you thought
Canada because you know and so does that
make sense it's kind leveraging the same
energy probably kind of in your workflow
but it'll allow you to I think capture
some market share um by with the
information you really already have
that's probably pretty top of Mind from
your research and all the work you're
doing honestly you knocked it out of the
park because the biggest thing I was
struggling with my channel was I almost
wanted to launch five channels because
we do residential commercial investing
we do Global referrals we do Canada and
I'm like oh my God like it's
overwhelming when in reality the way
you're explaining it is just being
focused on how I prep for my shoots and
I can talk about three different asset
classes and shoot three different videos
if I'm prepared I just I'm almost
falling forward doing so much I think I
need to spend twice as much time
prepping and then I'll probably get a
lot more out of the actual shoots right
I I would love the way you kind of
articulated that back to me because that
would be something I have to vehemently
protect myself I need to spend twice as
much prep time prepping I'm so busy
three-year-old one-year-old we hired 13
people in 2023 at think media
um trying to figure you know life's
crazy uh trying to stay healthy just
turn 40 what does that what do I mean
I'm so busy I have to spend twice as
much time in
planning like I have less time but I
need to spend more time because the more
time in planning calendar flip this
change that optimize that trip that'll
be inefficient okay that shoot day can
we just maximize that shoot day more the
more foresight the more
planning it's more painful in the moment
with all the fires burning maybe around
you but then you start creating a
flywheel of Leverage that
is worth it slow is smooth smooth is
fast the hypergrowth blueprint actually
is what helped us grow this channel my
personal Channel um I was chewing on it
for so long that what you just said to
me about like you know slowing down and
really understanding who you are and
what you do what I found was an hour
before we did this interview I was
prepping for it and in my brain is where
that line of well I'm kind of like Ryan
suran and Peter McKinnon put together
storytelling doing real estate that
actually gave me Clarity for my personal
channel so you killed two birds with one
stone and I think I'm gonna spend
2024 being a lot more intentional about
the videos that I'm putting out there I
love that Justin uh Angelique asked you
a question do you notice a difference in
the types of leads that come from your
YouTube channel versus other socials
absolutely so and it's funny because we
do listing videos and what Sean said
earlier to the previous guest is
absolutely true those are not the ones
that go the most viral but other sellers
will call you because it shows how
you're going to sell their home so I got
a lead off YouTube and it was a 1.8
million listing and she was sold like I
had the listing the day I walked in for
the appointment because they had watched
like six hours of my content and I
actually have another house that they're
building that's like 3.5 that I'll get
by proxy so the YouTube leads I get the
quality I would take one YouTube Lead
over 50 to 100 other online leads any
day of the week it's amazing when did
you first post any kind of videos
2014 so you've been doing it a long time
so what would you encourage people as
far as their mindset if they're scared
to get on camera if they're awkward at
first and just the process of turning
into the Creator you are now I I would
say you just got to press record you say
it all the time right I think my early
videos I didn't really put that much
effort into my channel but I was still
somewhat consistent um when I got
serious about it in 2020 21 and I just
started pressing record and I stopped
worrying about the vanity metrics you
told me this actually in clubhouse um
subscriber count and Views and I just
focused on clickthrough rate and
retention I was suddenly wasn't attached
to the outcome so if every video didn't
go viral it didn't really matter I think
it's consistent action over time helps
you refine who you're speaking to and
who you are and then creating the videos
becomes a lot easier so just press
record how hard is the market where
you're at right now it's it's super
tough but we're busier than we've ever
been because again like I'm not the
smartest the strongest I don't have the
most talent I wasn't given the keys to
the kingdom by a family that had a real
estate business but we are unreasonably
consistent for an unreasonably long
enough time that we can't fail so we're
actually killing it even though the
Market's really really hard up here
right now so would you agree that
embracing YouTube and social and online
branding overall personal branding that
they're it's not hype to say you can
build a Recession Proof personal brand
yeah absolutely so I think of pillar of
content so YouTube has become my pillar
once I shoot the content that becomes my
newsletter it becomes my Twitter thread
it becomes my reals that I shoot on
Instagram so like yeah YouTube as the
pillar I think even if YouTube went away
tomorrow the skill set that you get
being good at YouTube is going to
translate to every other aspect of your
business Justin any final question for
me so grateful to hang no I appreciate
you actually I know everybody's you know
always got focus on their business um I
think what you've done for the community
you taking that time early on on
clubhouse to pull me up on stage and
pour into me um the Trickle and the
butterfly effect is real we have a lot
of friends in close proximity you
mentioned some that I'm one step away
from as well too and I think I would
encourage anybody if anything to go buy
Sean's book give him some flowers share
out his next live stream like instead of
you doing something for for me I want
everybody watching this to do something
for you and think media because I think
you really helped a lot of people and
your servant leadership is probably what
I admire the most about you so well I
appreciate your kind words Justin and uh
Drea collected some information on the
back end I love that your core value is
do nothing out of selfish conceit or
vain humility but rather value others
above yourself I believe that's in
Philippians it is yeah founding
principle our brokerage and we live in a
world that doesn't make that easy
sometimes but if you stay focused you'll
find the
opportunities Justin you're a legend man
I appreciate you coming on and uh I know
you're already crushing it but I'm
excited to watch you guys continue to
rise in 2024 thanks Sean appreciate you
brother
cheers all right y'all smash like do you
have an aha moment I have a question to
answer for you but we do ahas and you
know the AHA is like helping us
socialize our learning helps us process
what have we've been learning what have
we've been hearing and what's an aha
moment even better if it's like an
action item I I I just I'm going to just
press record that's a good aha I'm going
to stop overthinking my next video and
I'm going to shoot and upload my next
video U maybe it's an aha of doing some
research maybe being more specific in
some of your local videos or anything
like that local search terms um and so
let me know one of your aha moments and
let's hit this question home Rapid
Repair in my videos with affiliate links
I fall into more of a Salesman fake type
mode as opposed to videos with a link I
feel more authentic can you give
advice well let me encourage you number
one um your self-awareness is
powerful
so one of two things could be
happening in your videos with affiliate
links you could be turning into more of
a
Salesman but not even know it
and it could be turning people off or or
maybe it doesn't turn people off but
like just your self-awareness of like
wow um I think it shows you've made a
lot more progress maybe than you realize
if that makes sense self-awareness is a
superpower and it's very rare anybody
have a family member who comes who might
come over for Christmas or Hanukkah or
the holidays and they're not very
self-aware yeah self-awareness is a
superpower and sometimes when we have
self-awareness we're not making an
excuse for an issue we want to improve
or or a weakness we want to improve but
it does go a long way if somebody could
say yeah that's something I get
something I'm working on so I just want
to encourage
you like acknowledging and identifying
the problem is the first op is the first
step to solving the problem so my advice
I guess would just be okay how can I
work
on my money mindset how can I work
on being authentic like how can I just
how can I maybe am I is there something
is there is there a false belief I have
about affiliate marketing am I moving
into a more sales mode because I don't
fully believe in the thing I'm
recommending then maybe you step back
from recommending that thing my I want
to close the
gap personally to say okay I am pumped
about recommending the Sony fx30 like I
don't need I and and uh so I I think the
self-awareness is the super power I
think just trying to shift your
messaging and then maybe to stop
overthinking it like
um and this is what I mean you're gonna
have impostor
syndrome we've probably never really
talked about
this like the nature of creating YouTube
content is an emotional an emotional
roller coaster that could lead you down
a lot of paths and I think this is what
we need to remember just because you
think the thought doesn't mean it's true
or doesn't mean you have to believe it
it or or just because you think the
thought is now awareness to steer a
different direction here's what I mean
the sheer nature of creating content and
talking on camera is so weird you might
start having things like I watch that
back I'm so
fake you know what I mean like man I'm
just so fake um or I watch that back is
that is that what I sound like why do I
do that with my hands when I get on
camera that's like it's not even me you
might get haters or trolls that say
something and it actually you're just
trying like you're just out there in the
ring there's like that quote like the
one on the the critic is not the one who
counts it's never the critic that counts
it's the person that's in the ring and
getting in the ring you're gonna have
self-doubt impostor syndrome why' I do
that you watch it back and you be like
that felt salesy so I've watched
something back and I'll be like man that
kind of felt salesy or you know what
like the way I worded that was kind of
wrong I don't want to stretch the truth
I kind of stretched the truth there but
I think we can over catastrophize
if you have good intent and you're
watching it back and always trying to
improve and what am I trying to improve
authenticity vulnerability love
integrity that's what I'm shooting for
here's what I can guarantee you at think
media I make a lot of mistakes I've made
a lot of mistakes Sean is do you have a
perfect track record of always just
being perfectly honest in every video
about every brand and everything you've
done no and anybody who says they do is
the big
person to worry about because I
guarantee they have like we all are
working out you know our messaging
working out so I think if you have uh
good intent and
self-awareness um and then you're just
intentional about how you want to come
across and this is why we continue to
invest in coaching and continue to maybe
become more more centered and speak out
of an authentic place I I'll land the
plane here um this has been a long
answer but it's really got me inspired
you you know you fall into salesman fake
typee mode as opposed to other things
like I look back at my old videos and
the old Shan was so what is the best
microphone to film and like just it
wasn't that it was a Salesman but there
was like this different character this
was like the
not a little more chill little more West
Coast Sean it was it was like a little
more caffeinated 10 years younger Shan
whatever um and I look back and and I
sometimes maybe have gone from just
being who I thought I should be just
cranking up the energy maybe a little
too far early on in my career one of the
reasons why I like shouted because
technology 10 years ago was so bad in
church when I was doing the church
videos we only had the on camera mic and
we'd have somebody like way back here
filming so I'd be like so what is up
guys because I started learning that the
only way to hear it was how far away the
mic was and then I started to learn that
this mic is a different experience if
you're going to work on this mic you can
come in and we can get close I can
welcome you to the coffee with canel
romance
hour where we get hot and heavy quickly
with YouTube advice so learning your so
what's the point I look back and I'm
like dude that guy was like a character
what a fake no I was trying I'm learning
I was giving it my best shot and then I
watched my game tape and just like you
did I watched it back and I still try to
grow and I continue to invest in myself
remember at the beginning we we need to
learn new skills and we need to date Sam
sales and marketing and we need to stay
positive just keep going we're getting
1% better so then it's
like I you know start getting more into
and and I get
feedback and there's been times when
I've been sitting and recording it's a
blessing to have somebody else in the
room like Melissa or Kyle I've been
sitting down I've been recording a video
and I'll do a version and Kyle will be
like yeah that was all right I mean
seemed kind of fake thanks bro but like
because I'm just you're just trying like
and and I know my intent is good but
communication we could inflect up down
we could be overly you know and so I
sometimes think we go a little too
insular and we just get stuck in our own
head and we're like oh man GE I'm so
terrible we just get so we get super
negative and or like over we just
overthink things maybe it's just me
maybe it's a little bit of the obsessive
compulsive uh kind of n of my
personality um but let me encourage you
and encourage everybody watching and I
hope this rant has kind of been valuable
like it's never the critic that counts
and might I challenge you that could
also go for your inner critic I think
the credit belongs to the courageous and
who are the cage courageous those that
are not
cowering in fear those whose lives are
not marked by how much attention to
detail they pay to other people's lives
I am not impressed by somebody who's
built their brand or built their world
or is addicted to drama and they're just
known for how much attention to detail
they pay to other people's lives it's
never the critic that counts it's the
person that's in the ring the person
that's pressing record the person that's
getting on camera and if somebody's like
you post your first couple videos and
they go you're fake you come off weird
you talk weird well we all do because
we're just getting on camera for the
first time but the critic who's pointing
that out what are you they're sitting in
their mom's basement making no videos
trying to build their brand off of
tearing others down empathetically are
probably emotionally wounded and
insecure and they've given up on their
dreams so now they're trying to tear
down everybody who hasn't like so that
person which I know those comments can
be real and this is a good conversation
for real estate agents and people who
are just wanting to get on camera
because maybe one of the biggest hurdles
you're gonna have to come over is just
the mindset what if I don't look
professional what if I hurt my brand
what if I seem salesy talking to a
camera is so weird it's so awkward
you're in the ring let me give you
credit if you're you're in the ring if
you pressed record and the video was
terrible you deserve the credit because
99% of people
won't they're going to stay in
fear they're going to
hesitate they're going to
overthink and they're probably going to
critique people they're gonna find
somebody's blowing up on social then the
critics come out of the woodwork that's
why I say I see you in the comments but
I never see you at the
bank comment section is a cool place to
be thank you for leaving comments but
you know what's better than leaving a
comment is creating a video create
something press record go do it Go
hustle go put in the work my friends
this has been the coffee with Kel Show
we have one other
question that took me down a little uh
rabbit hole but um I hope that y'all are
feeling grateful today I'm gonna hit
this last question rapid fire so we can
end at the top of the hour shooting a
think video podcast episode with my
friend John Acuff a little bit L later
all it takes is a goal let's get our
goals right for 2024 what's of your
goals for
2024 and we'll end land the plane with
this question right here how do you find
time to create content where you're
actively working on your business shoot
Kyle 36 minute answer incoming just
kidding but kind of could could take it
there
so uh book recommendation and we'll link
it up in the show notes is a book called
buyback your time by Dan Martel think
media podcast episode recommendation is
my interview with Dan Martell about buy
back your time that'll be a really good
accelerator and
so that's kind of one answer is you've
got to number one do a Time audit how
much time do you have number
two do a you know priorities audit what
are your actual priorities you know what
are the essential tasks you have to do
every week number three identify
opportunities to what could I stop doing
this is unnecessary this isn't fruitful
or between creating content on YouTube
or doing this activity over there you
got to weigh them YouTube is more
valuable if at this exact moment you
know that if you make 10 cold calls you
know an hour I don't know 25 cold calls
an hour that actually two of those want
to follow up and that leads like there
might be a lever in your business that
you don't want to let go of because it
so clearly mathematically tracks towards
a business result okay well then that
one actually needs to stay up here but
then there's this thing over here where
you're like rearranging modules on your
website or something like rearranging
chairs on the Titanic like the ship's
going down you need to actually take
energy away from this and focus it on
Sam sales and marketing so you actually
can revive the the the crash that's
coming in your own personal business so
it's assessing priorities time
management all these things if you're an
individual and resources are scarce solo
creator
you got to do it that way and then
whatever time you find you invest that
time creating content and you got to
wear the two hats that's what most
people have to do in business in the
bootstrapping phase of being the Chief
Operating Officer of your business being
the Chief Executive Officer of your
business and being the chief marketing
officer Sean that's three roles yeah and
you got to wear all three hats you got
to run Ops run the vision run the
technical Ops in the detail
and run the marketing okay but then my
next question fluid levels is do you
know do you have
money um you know we just talked to
Justin he said he's got a creative
director he's got a videographer and you
don't go zero to 100 real quick like
Drake you might just go to a contractor
you work with once a month in Vegas if
you want to fly out to Vegas you could
hook up with Omar elori who's
doing four long forms and 20 verticals
for you you know and you come in and you
batch so you pay for a batch of videos
super smart or do that but that's
leveraged so what did you just do you
put on your calendar a shoot day you
could do that also by yourself you put
on your calendar a shoot day where you
hire a local videographer or whatever
and they come to your office and they
set up and you just batch as much
content as you can in one day it's a
leveraged activity so I think it's about
looking at leverage I think it's about
looking at your auditing your schedule
and then I would say definitely check
out the buyback Your Time episode with
Dan Martell and check out the book um
and that will serve you as we land the
plane today I know we've been sharing
some of our
uh our uh takeaways sales and Sam sales
and marketing we're out here capture
nurture convert yes great buy back your
time book uh Drea dropped it in the
think media Podcast chat too that's a
really good one to uh read going into
2020 4 do you have any books on your
reading list for 2024 let me know and um
lastly
um if you haven't watched real tube
class.com that is your next step uh we
gotta land the plane on coffee with
canel for today closing
time I'm not sure why I'm singing this
song but I love it so we just had our
think media party in Vegas with uh our
team Retreat and um we had a bus where
we went to Vegas went to a steakhouse
and everything
and I didn't know that Nolan Mark Trey
and Sam on the thick beia team were like
alltime dancers there was literally a
dance battle on the bus at our all team
Retreat you can actually see Clips on my
Instagram at Sean
canel um what's the point of saying that
uh oh yeah at the end of night though
cuz I was the DJ so I had the Bluetooth
on had to play that Closing Time song
and so anyways y'all know the song but
we got a close and so the next move is
to go to realtube class.com you can
check out our free YouTube strategy
class for real estate agents so fun
definitely a different content than we
normally share and really a no-brainer
if you are a real estate professional of
any kind or service provider you're in
mortgage so head to real tube class .c
my name is Sean canel rhymes with
YouTube channel thanks so much for
checking out this episode of coffee with
canel today and I can't wait to connect
with you in a future episode Peace